the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so welcome back today we're gonna look
at the modular synthesizer and our area
of focus right now it's still looking at
musical interfaces a lot of people
present the modular synthesizer in the
context of basic synthesis techniques or
in sort of the development of musical
instruments I think it's very useful for
us to think of the modular synthesizer
as a type of musical interface and
particularly the interface available
through the creative patching and
combination of modules so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna look at a little
bit of the history of the development of
modular synthesizer starting with the
giant RCA since and then moving on to
the mug we're gonna spend a little time
with the basic mode design and look at
some of the basic synthesis techniques
we're going to do that by looking at the
emulation of virtual mode that we have
available through our tears very nice
virtual mug instrument plugin which is
going to give us a way to hear some of
the sounds and see some of the
approaches to patching this instrument
and the next time we meet in workshop
mode next Tuesday we're going to build
some similar designs in PD using the
martingale library and explore some of
these approaches as well we're gonna
listen to some music and then if we get
to it talk about some semi modular
synths and see the design go from fully
modular synthesizers to semi modular and
non modular synthesizers which is
invaluable trajectory to see so coming
up on the horizon we have a brief quiz
on Thursday keep that in mind your music
technology case studies are due the
draft is due on Tuesday if you have any
questions about this as you approach
this feel free to drop me an email or
the like and that's it for now any
questions
okay so now with the modular synthesizer
we see numerous things start to start to
come together we saw in the early
studios used by Vera's by Stockhausen
and others this cobbling together of
various components and interconnecting
them into sound producing devices we see
with the modular synthesizer these
components are to solidify into a single
common collection of entities with these
semi modular designs we see these this
solidification happened even more and
the designs sort of solidify into a
single common thing there wasn't
anything shockingly new about the
technologies used in the modular
synthesizer again they were technologies
that had been around for 10 or 20 years
but really the interface and the design
and the integration of these components
in my view was the really important
thing voltage control the ability to
interconnect and control these devices
with voltages was really the key
technology that made this synthesizer
more flexible more powerful and more
creative for the operator now we start
with the RCA synthesizer which isn't
really a modular synthesizer to my
knowledge this device had a fairly fixed
signal path so it wasn't really modular
it had components but you couldn't
interconnect the components with patch
cords you couldn't radically change the
type of sounds that have made now this
synthesizer came in two different forms
there was the first one which later
became known as the mark 1 and then the
mark 2 the later version of this this
decision was the result of quite a bit
of research by Olson and Baylor who were
working at RCA for a number of years the
homes text nicely describes their early
research with music synthesis
technologies does anybody recall what
they were trying to do in the beginning
Olson and Baylor their first attempt at
synthesis was directed towards a certain
activity
recall they're trying to synthesize
Steven Walter pop tunes pop melodies
basic melodies using essentially Markov
chains and they're trying to create a
machine that could compose simple
melodies by analyzing basic tunes and
then re synthesizing them in that
process they develop some technologies
for creating oscillators and filters and
that led to their first RCA synthesizer
so this device used essentially tuning
fork based oscillators so their basic
oscillator was a tuning fork that was
set in motion and picked up
electromagnetically and that signal was
then divided to shift into different
octaves and transformed into a square
wave to create a rich tone and then they
filtered that tone to create the variety
of Tambor's that the instrument could
make the synthesis the device featured a
number of filters as well high and
low-pass filters and this really kind of
bizarre resonator chain which is an
interesting sort of selective filter
this image here is from their first
publication on the synthesizer from 1955
and it's also reproduced in the halls
book we can see the basic way that the
synthesizer worked information was
encoded on something kind of like a
piano roll but just storing control
information in a binary representation
here rather than using a vacuum brushes
are used to pick up when an opening in
the hole was to trigger a circuit the
frequency source here is those
oscillators controlled by tuning forks
and that signal is then split by the
octave er and then it's has a frequency
glider which allows the transition
between pitches the growth and decay
which is a fancy name for an envelope
generator or not
fancy I guess a historic various high
pass low pass filters volume control low
frequency modulator probably for adding
vibrato or other slow changes to the
sound resonator change that's that
unique filter I was talking about Tambor
control probably additional filters or
I'm not exactly sure what that last
component did but that's something to
look at and then finally all going to a
nice record cutter which allowed you to
record the sound so there were two
nearly identical voices that could be
used and controlled by this paper roll
so partly out of Olson and bailers
earlier research in synthesizing pop
tunes they approach the synthesizer as a
device that needed to be controlled not
by a keyboard not by some other type of
interface but by a type of notation and
their notation was this punched hole
paper record which again is kind of like
a piano roll but different because
rather than a one-to-one relationship
with parameters and their values these
are essentially three and four but bit
codes that determine frequency octave
Tambor the envelope growth and decay and
volume so frequency is determined by
these four on and off switches which
give us sixteen possible values but they
only used twelve octave could be
selected similarly here Tambor the
envelope volume etc this role right
there shows us the necessary information
to encode these six pitches so you can
imagine working with this device would
be a little tedious but it offered
explicit complete control this nice
diagram also from that original article
shows us a massive simplification of the
device going from reading the role to
the to synthesizer channels mixer
amplifier and then
direct to disc cutting lace some notable
thing about this it was really the first
attempt to sort of parameterize musical
information in a very rigorous and
complete way we saw with the player
piano an earlier attempt at
parameterization but here we're starting
to parameterize tambour amplitude
envelopes and volume and level controls
at a greater degree than we had with the
player piano also important about this
instrument is it was not designed for
performance it was really designed as a
sort of machine were you composed in
advance and played back what you had
notated that was the mark 1 the mark 1
was housed at Princeton University and
that started a relationship with
Columbia and Princeton University which
led to Columbia and Princeton getting a
grant from the Rockefeller Foundation to
buy the second version of this synth the
RCA Mark 2 this synth was very similar
to the mark 1 except for it added a
white noise generator which was useful
for creating a variety of noisier
percussive sounds it had four voices
instead of two it had a microphone input
and it had some variable frequency
oscillators similar to the RCA Mark one
it was a room sized giant beast of a
synthesizer we can see in this picture
we can see the disk cutters here we can
see also some tape eventually they did
add tape machines and we can see the
paper readers there notice that we don't
see really a patch Bay or patch cords
this was a modular synthesizer and that
it had modules but it wasn't freely
interconnected in the way that we later
find with our mug and Buchla
synthesizers now I sent you guys the
link to this demo recording which has
this great narrator helping us
along the way this demo record was made
in 1955 I believe it was a recording of
the mark 2 the reason why is because in
this demonstration they use filtered
white noise and I think this is a very
nice example where they try to
synthesize the sound of a complete dance
band so they had four voices so they use
some of the voices for bass percussion
and melody let's listen to a little of
this
that's the hi-hat sounds and that's the
bass and here's everything all together
we can also synthesize the part where
each tone has a rapid growth and slowly
cave like this let's go back to that
dance man notice the white noise being
used for the sort of snare like sound
there
so as this demo record shows and as the
history of Olsson and bailers work shows
they were very interested in using the
synthesizers to generate pop music which
is kind of interesting because what it
became used for was not popular music
but music of composers like Milton
Babbitt Mario David ASCII and other
composers working at the Columbia
Princeton studios one of our listening
for today was Phil amel babbitt's 1964
composition that used the RCA
synthesizer let's listen to a little bit
of this to remind you guys what this
sounds like
so there's three sources of sound in
this composition
what are they three sources of sound
right the live voice anybody notice or
recall there's also pre-recorded voice
so there's some tape recorded and
processed voice sounds in here which are
used to create some very nice sort of
distance echo and sort of some depth to
the voice and actually up in my view one
of the one of the most interesting
things about this piece is how the tape
part blends of sort of the synthesis and
acts as sort of an intermediary talked
about this piece
sporadic what do you mean sporadic
jagged yeah they follow us and pattern
to yeah well I mean I took there's sort
of this jagged jerky gestural shape to a
lot of the musical parts and that's
clear in the voice and also in the
synthesis synthesizer parts yeah let's
jump to the end in here now Babbitt was
using a method of organization that
we've talked about previously what was
that method of organization serialism or
the twelve-tone technique what did the
RCA synthesizer provide facilities for
twelve-tone composers was it well suited
for that I mean Olson and Baylor wanted
to use it to do popular music right you
could you get all your parameters were
fixed on the roll so you could compose
very especially carefully crafted lines
and a very organized way and that's very
much what we hear here it's kind of I
think ironic in that Olson availa
imagined this instrument originally to
create an endless variety of pop tunes
to sell on the commercial market and of
course it ended up being used to create
some very esoteric non-commercial music
in the end and that's one of our many
examples of well I guess unintended
consequences of certain technologies
other comments or reflections on this
piece
to use the operatic voice with it as
opposed to like other singing styles
because in connection with synthesizer
in Delhi those sort of strange timbre of
operatic singing bride became this like
this thing that was more like a like a
thing to listen to it then typically
what operatic singing yeah that's
interesting I wonder I mean for me the
really second thing is the vibrato
because the vibrato is really really
wide contrast between that wide vibrato
and the more flat tones we're getting
out the synthesizer are you hearing
something else as well
yeah parts because they he like speeds
are up and slows her down and so this
thing happens with the vibrato right
where they like yeah very tight or even
looser and lower and there's this really
great interplay between that and and
this
yeah I agree yep sound I reminded me a
lot of sense picture oh yeah yeah well a
lot of the early sounds of early
synthesizers were used in science
fiction and films since Forbidden Planet
and even before that with the theremin
the connection has been there for some
time we don't hear a lot of variety of
Tambor's and colors with the synthesizer
a lot of it is sort of sinusoidal or
filtered waveforms so there's not a huge
variety of sounds out of this synth but
it didn't provide a tremendous amount of
control as we can tell by looking at the
control information available on the
tape yeah I mean it's worth looking at
further I suspect given babbitt's
inclinations that both pitch and the
other parameters were serialized so it's
very likely he had the opportunity to
serialize envelopes and serialized the
tamra controls of the sins so I think
it's very likely that he probably did
which is similar to approach would have
taken by Stockhausen who was rigorously
exploring some of these things but with
the RCA synthesizer this became very
notable in a way that wasn't possible
before did you have another come okay so
to innovators followed the RCA
synthesizer with devices that were more
flexible than the RCA synthesizer they
were more flexible in that they allowed
the operator to reconnect the macho the
modules in various ways rather than that
fixed sequence of oscillator filter etc
the these devices allow the operator to
interconnect them in a variety of
different ways and also allowed the
operator to control them in a variety of
different ways not with punched paper
but with various types of input devices
bucha generally gets credit for coming a
little bit before Moog his devices were
very diverse and often custom-designed
for particular people particular studios
his interest as a composer himself was
in creating diverse and unique
instruments not really in creating a
commercial market for the synthesizer so
he not only explored a wide variety of
different modules that use noise and
randomness and in different ways but
also various types of input devices
other than the keyboard and our readings
for today emphasize the point about how
Buchla initially didn't want a keyboard
control for his instrument and Moog
embraced that which is an issue we'll
talk about when we talk about the pinch
and troppo reading in 1965 he releases
the buco box without a keyboard a very
popular instrument 1970 he has this 200
series electric music box which you can
see there also doesn't have a keyboard
but has a variety of sliders knobs and
other interface components in the 70s he
released some portable devices this one
although apparently I think home says
that only 200 of these were made how
wouldn't you like one of these he
use the keyboard at times but notice
that this is a touch sensitive keyboard
and probably does some things we
wouldn't expect small portable modular
synthesizer if you can find one of these
get it bucola is still making
synthesizers they're very expensive but
they really offer some unique designs
looking at his designs you can go to his
website our really fascinating creative
approaches to the synthesizer bucha is
sort of a separate thread from that of
mogh
because mogs instruments were dedicated
to meeting the needs the demands of
musicians our readings make that very
clear he worked with musicians in a
variety of ways he invited musicians to
come to his factory and explore his
instruments he adapted his instruments
to the demands of musicians in order to
meet their needs and really through that
made a very successful
commercial instrument now we've already
talked about how Moga started with the
theremin as a kid
creating theremin kits in his garage in
1954 he published this article in radio
and television news about his design for
a tube-based theremin this article is
great you can check it out online it
also has the whole schematic diagram for
the circuit at this time in the 40s and
50s there was this whole kit bit
building culture and a lot of interest
in building theremin so his design
became very popular and attracted a lot
of attention he published another
article in 1961 using a transistor based
theremin that was actually featured on
the cover of this magazine and also got
him a lot of attention
he was then started by then had a
business he and his dad were selling
theremins out of their garage theremin
kits by the 60s he meets a composer by
the name of Deutsche who knew mogh
because of the theremin is theremin kits
and started to invent wanted to know
about well if you can do some other
types of synthesizing devices some other
types of devices that allowed you to
take basic oscillators interconnect them
and put them under flexible control Moog
develops his first synthesizer the 900
series 1965 this device wasn't
distributed broadly it was used mostly
by composers and some studios in 1966 he
patents his low-pass filter which
becomes a very important part of his
synthesizer because it allowed to take a
rich wide bandwidth sound and control
its timbre and give it a very crisp
tone we'll hear some of that sound very
shortly this people say that this was
the only thing that Moke patented but
there are some other patents associated
with the mode name it was definitely the
first device that he patented and the
low-pass filter was novel in that it had
a particularly steep roll-off curve so
it was able to really focus the sound
underneath the cutoff frequency and had
an adjustable resonance which provided a
nice peak at that cutoff frequency now
it's in 1967 that he releases his first
real commercial product the series
systems 1 2 and 3 this is an earlier
device we can see with this one the
keyboard we can see some of the basic
modules and we can see also a ribbon
controller another type of input device
that he explored this got later refined
into devices of this sort which is very
often what we see when we imagine the
Moog synthesiser here we have a number
of oscillators filters up here and this
over here is a sequencer which we're
actually going to talk about sequencing
next time we meet also the keyboard and
the ribbon controller as well so with
the systems 1 2 & 3 in 1967 there was
some standard packages you could buy but
you could still buy individual modules
for your own synthesizer and this nice
price list
shows us some of the prices of these
devices we could get a
voltage-controlled amplifier for a
hundred and fifty dollars fair price
that low-pass filter
voltage controlled low pass high pass
filter four hundred and seventy five
dollars for one filter in 1968 that's
pretty expensive these synthesizers were
extremely expensive but they started to
be sold and commercialized and people
started to buy them but one thing in
particular led to the explosion of the
Moog industry and that was Wendy
Carlos's switched-on Bach recording
recorded in 1968 released in 69 and
garnered a huge amount of attention to
the Moog synthesizer will talk about
Wendy Carlos and her recording in a
little bit but let's review some of the
concepts of the modular synthesizer so
we have two basic components we have
things that generate sound like our
oscillators and other devices and we
have components that modify those sounds
so we have these two different types of
modules that can be interconnected and
modified the input for a module is
either the knobs on the front panel or
another voltage and some devices allow
you to switch between using the knob or
a voltage as an input or using both
using the knob to set a basic level and
then the input voltage to adjust it
further the output of these modules is
another voltage which can be
interconnected two modules further down
the line within the modular synthesizer
we have two types of signals we have
control signals and audio signals both
of these depending on the design can be
interconnected in various ways audio
signals are the things that were used to
sounds represented as of bipolar voltage
voltage ranges with generally between
negative three and three volts sometimes
higher or wider ranges were possible
control signals were also voltages but
generally unipolar voltages between
maybe zero and +5 volts
these were often more
slowly moving signals that could be used
to control the parameters of another
module control signals were used
obviously to shape envelopes and these
envelopes could be applied to parameters
other than the amplitude of the sound
such as a cutoff frequency or the bike
now a key concept of the modular
synthesizer was the ability to reuse the
modules we could use an oscillator to
produce a tone and hear that tone of the
oscillator we could also use a module an
oscillator to shape the amplitude of a
sound and produce a tremolo or to
modulate the frequency of another
oscillator and produce a vibrato or use
the output of an oscillator to modulate
the cutoff frequency to create a
variable Tambor to a sound I'm going to
demonstrate all those in a second this
ability to reuse these modules to mix
audio signals and control signals and
transform one to the other was really
the key feature of the modular
synthesizer combined with voltage
control and gave it a great degree of
flexibility now in this sort of golden
age of the modular synthesizer when you
sat down to this instrument you got
nothing for free you sat down it didn't
make any sound in order to make a sound
you had to design an instrument so the
interface in order to make a sound
became patching you had the patch to
make a sound
no sounds were given to you and this
promoted a huge degree of freedom and
creativity in the design of sounds we
see over the history of synthesizers
this starts to decrease and so in the
late 60s is when we have the most
freedom and as the 70s move on we see
some the sizes that reduce the ability
of patching and make it easier to get a
sound more automatically and then by the
early 80s we have synthesizers that are
programmable but have very little in
terms of a customizable interface some
of the basic components of this
synthesizer these are screenshots of
virtual synths which is kind of amusing
but
they allow us to see more clearly some
of the designs of these synthesizers so
our basic oscillators or voltage
controlled oscillators generally
provided a control for frequency often
the range of the frequency knob would be
variable in steps so we have a loaf
dedicated low frequency switch for low
frequency oscillators and then we have
various higher ranges which use the
terminology derived from organs 32 foot
16 foot 8 foot and the like we have the
ability to get different waveforms from
the same oscillator which is a nice
convenience of such devices we have
various noise sources and we'll hear
example of those as well and we have
sample-and-hold generators which allow
us to take an input signal and sample it
periodically to create a stepped shape
I'll demonstrate that in a little bit as
well now our modular synthesizers
usually had some sort of mixing control
some ability to combine signals and this
sometimes was under control of another
voltage so we have voltage control
amplifiers or VCAs
sometimes we have mixers that use
various toggles or on-off switches this
is from the design of the mini Moog
where the various oscillators had a
level control and then a toggle switch
and some devices had various types of
matrix mixing and patching controls
which are very very cool
this EMS synthesizer the synth II synth
I allowed you to control the routing of
signals rather than through patch cords
through a matrix this was a template
used to help you remember your patch
with this synth these scents are very
cool if you can find one grab it notice
the convenient handle you can take it
with you all of our synthesizers have
various types of filters a VCF or
voltage control filter allows you to
adjust the parameters with a voltage the
low-pass filter and high-pass filter
being the most common a band pass filter
and other
is also found in our modular synthesizer
we have various types of envelope
generators the envelope is a unipolar
signal that we can apply to the
amplitude of a sound but we can also
apply the envelope to other musical
parameters the key thing about an
envelope is it's a control signal that's
designed to be triggered it's a control
signal that's designed to start at a
certain time and end as opposed to
something like a low frequency
oscillator that is continuous and
ongoing the adsr is probably the most
common type of envelope control on these
early modular synthesizers although
there were other varieties as well there
was a are filters and attack decay
sustain filters various simplifications
of the adsr model the key approach to
using the modular synthesizer at this
time is often a pro called subtractive
synthesis the idea of subtractive
synthesis is we start with a rich
complex tone and we use our filters to
take away from that tone and get the
sound that we're looking at this is part
of the reason why Muggs low-pass filter
was so important because we could start
with a complex tone and then use the low
pass filter to shape out the frequencies
that we did not want so our basic
approach of working in subtractive
synthesis would be to start with a rich
complex tone to cut out some of those
frequencies apply amplitude envelopes to
vary the amplitude shape of that sound
and then use modulation to vary the
parameters and this starts to become
really interesting when we modulate the
modulators and we'll listen to what that
sounds like in a second questions
comments ideas
okay so let's hear what this sounds like
now probably the most basic approach on
one of the most common approaches to
create a complex town would be combining
multiple oscillators and this design is
embodied in some of the early Moog
synthesizers where we have three
oscillators like these three oscillators
right here all under one driver to
control the three oscillators the idea
embodied in the interface here is that
we're going to create a rich tone by
combining oscillators we can tune each
of these oscillators to different
octaves and slight tuning differences
but they're all going to be under a
single control let's listen to what this
sounds like so our first example if we
start off with just a single oscillator
so here we're hearing a sawtooth
waveform and I'm taking it from this
oscillator here and just dropping it
over into my big adsr envelope there if
we want to hear a sine tone we can just
replace that same time and we have our
triangle waveform here
our triangle waveform sounds dead at
that range that's unexpected
oh let's go back to this and wonder
further as our saw and then we have our
a square wave which also is not
performing well strangely okay
so that's our basic oscillators now we
can combine these to create a rich tone
so here what I've done is combined the
sound of three oscillators and let me
tune them all the same first
so we're actually hearing three
oscillators and if you think about what
you think of a moke sounding like this
sort of
thick sound is very much what we think
about we're hearing sawtooth and square
waves here at different octaves let me
vary the octaves of this a little bit
here that square wave at the higher
octave there
or if I move up one of the Sawtooth ways
or if I set them all to low registers
now we can tune each of these
oscillators separately and a very common
practice would be to make the
oscillators slightly out of tune to
create an even thicker sound so if I
tune each of these oscillators out a
little bit from the center let me go
even further
now right there it sounds like attitude
oscillators but if I bring this closer
together we get a thick sound rather
than an out-of-tune sound let me shift
this one up an octave or two
and let me set this to be a little bit
more attitude
you don't hear it as out of tune
oscillators you hear it as a single
complex tone now we can see already that
most of these early modular designs were
designed to be monophonic so produce one
sound at a time early on it was figured
out that it'd be pretty nice to be able
to control the transition between these
monophonic voices and so we have the use
of portamento control this was available
in the RCA synthesizer as well and this
would often set the amount of glide
between adjacent pitches so
right here we're hearing one note at a
time if I set the glide
it's a little long there'll you make it
a little longer
which was used very prominently by
musicians
to create transitions between notes and
it's really one of the most common
sounds from these early monophonic
synthesizers questions it seems like a
weird order it becomes such a central
thing or even too late to decide well I
mean if the normal musician can control
this for instance on a guitar or other
string instrument even a lot of wind
instruments as well and I think the idea
was some musical passages you would want
to be staccato and short and and broken
in other cases depending on the context
you would want to have that sort of
glide control if you want to make it
sound like a theremin you can set it all
the way up and then get continuous sort
of pitch variations yeah exactly
okay so our first step in subtractive
synthesis is creating a complex tone and
we've done that by combining and
detuning oscillators we can use a
variety of different wave shapes with
those oscillators and we can detune them
and we can add three or I don't know
should we go crazy should we if we want
to add some more of us I don't know what
is six sound like let's it was throwing
a sine tone
that's kind of nice
and let's throw in another sawtooth okay
you get the idea now so we've produced
our complex tone the next basic step of
subtractive synthesis is to apply a
filter and this is where most patented
low-pass filter comes into play and why
his steep roll-off curve was so valuable
we take our complex tone generated by
three or more oscillators and we filter
it and let's start off with just the
filtered a little bit ahead of where we
want to be let's start first with our
complex tone
there's our complex tone and our filter
provides cutoff frequency to shape the
timbre of that sound and a resonance
control to set the amount of amplitude
on the peak of the cutoff frequency
one of the design features of mugs
low-pass filter was that it could self
resonate so if the resonance was set
loud enough we could actually produce a
very clear sinusoidal sound at the
cutoff frequency you get the idea
so there's our low pass filter taking
our thick tone put it through a low pass
filter one of the most common things we
want to do and one of the easiest
modular synthesizer is we can take a
sine tone or some other wave shape and
use it to modulate the cutoff frequency
there it's a little fast let me slow it
down so now we're modulating the cutoff
frequency by a sine tone whose frequency
I can control and whose depth I can
control here we'd have to scale it this
is much harder to do with a real sense
but this makes it nice and easy
so a very common sound using a low
frequency oscillator to control the
cutoff frequency yeah yeah let's hear so
yeah you can definitely notice it
because here we're hearing the smooth
transition so let's try a square wave
right actually here the steps pattern if
we speed this up this is actually a
pretty cool
we get a nice switching and then if we
do the let's try a triangle waveform
we'll get a it's not as smooth as a sign
we'll get a
should we give it two percent yeah oh I
just wanted to clarify that all the
audio outputs are also these uses
control outputs
there's no like separation between
different since had different designs in
terms of that with the mogh I will
I believe you except for the voltage
ranges sometimes you would need to scale
an audio input some devices you would
need to sort of transform your voltage
before you could use it but you could
take an audio oscillator and use it as a
control voltage if it could perform at a
slow enough rate as a low frequency
oscillator some designs you would need a
dedicated little frequency oscillator
because it couldn't perform slowly in a
reliable way
that would be an often an issue why
sometimes there'd be a dedicated low
frequency oscillator but with computers
doing low frequency oscillation is easy
so it's it's it's more interoperable if
you think you do really cool things that
you took audio signal that was not
synthesized but recorded yeah and
amplified and made to control things
like absolutely
is there a responsiveness if you like
with
before about controllability persons
have audio signals is that the control
tends to be absolutely obviously audio
is at a higher rate yeah right but that
anything is that a problem what if you
wanted to modulate say the the you know
filter with your voice exactly yeah I
mentioned in passing that the RCA
synthesizer had a microphone input and
most synthesizers had this one doesn't
show us a good example of that but had
microphone inputs we could take an
analog signal use a low pass filter to
smooth out the edges and use that to
drive some other parameters so it was
possible to take other inputs use them
to control your musical parameters that
general technique is something we call
envelope following or weed and sometimes
there would be dedicated envelope
followers in these early synths to make
that even easier yeah okay so what we
just did was have our dense combination
of oscillators and we use an LFO to
shape the sound in a periodic way a very
common probably the most common approach
to subtractive synthesis so common that
it was embodied in the design of the
mini Moog a few years later from the
time of this synthesizer was using an
envelope to control the cutoff frequency
why would you use an envelope to control
the cutoff frequency
so with the LFO we get that continuous
change in the Tambor no matter when we
trigger the note why would we want to
use an envelope which we you generally
use to control the amplitude to control
the cutoff frequency of a filter any
ideas that's right that's right many
real instruments have different Tambor's
over the course of their envelope many
instruments are often brighter at the
initial onset the articulation and then
sort of darken as the tone sustains so a
very common approach is to take the to
use a or pull it up envelope and here
I'm using an adsr set to trigger when I
press a note to control the cutoff
frequency of the filter and I'll start
off with the modulation of this being
small
here on the onset the initial little
bump in the frequency will you make this
broader and even broader and I'll start
off with the lower start point so that's
an extreme setting we're using the adsr
to control the cutoff frequency and I
can adjust the attack so if the attack
is quick we'll get a bright sound at the
very beginning and then it'll get dark
over here a synthesizer sound like that
before maybe probably the most common
approach subtractive synthesis use an
envelope to control the cutoff frequency
of a rich tone if I set the attack to be
longer even longer still
we get a very slow increase in the
cutoff frequency and then I was so long
it didn't come back down there we go
good questions so again that approach
was so common it was embodied in nearly
almost every synthesizer that came after
the Moog this idea of applying a filter
to the cutoff frequencies some designs
like the mini Moog even had a dedicated
envelope just to control the cutoff
frequency so what else could we do with
the modular synthesizer well we could do
amplitude modulation and ring modulation
where we modulate the amplitude of the
sound either with a sinusoidal shape or
some other shape and we can use this to
create tremolo effects when we use a low
frequency oscillator or amplitude
modulation or ring modulation effects as
we speed up the modulation so in the
first example here we're taking the
output of our three oscillators here and
we're putting them into what is
essentially a voltage controlled
amplifier and we're modulating the
voltage of the amplifier by another
oscillator so
so this is a later you controlling the
amplitude of our rich tone as we speed
this up we get a sort of tremolo sound
and as we take this oscillator into the
audio range this is a great example of
being able to use our modules for both
audio and control ray signals we start
to get some amplitude modulated
sounds and if I increase the modulation
and again low frequency and as before we
can change the wave shape of the
amplitude modulation between our other
wave shapes so here I'm using a sinusoid
we could use squares or triangles or
other shapes as well now of course the
next thing to do is modulate the
modulators so if I vary the modulation
of the modulator so here I'm using one
oscillator to control the frequency of
another oscillator that being used to
control the amplitude of our rich tone
controlled by three oscillators we get a
gradual shift from tremolo to amplitude
modulation as I speed this up and let's
try something even faster
ever not here
let's try one more thing
so there we're going we're doing sort of
variable rate amplitude modulation where
the variance in the rate is determined
by this other oscillator let's try one
more in this super high speed
all right you get the idea questions
so that's amplitude modulation ring
modulation closely related to amplitude
modulation sometimes there would be
dedicated devices for doing ring
modulation on the mug there was a
dedicated ring modulator that used a
special circuit that was quite popular
let's just hear a little bit about how
that ring modulation sounds like now
here I'm using an envelope to modulate
the frequency of ring modulation so that
we get a dynamic contour over the length
of the event
which is kind of fun good so that's
amplitude modulation we can use our
oscillators to control frequency and
very yes sir right is that still the
same I'm using the different envelope
generator so I'm using I guess I'm using
a different envelope generator I'm
triggering them at the same time but I'm
using a different adsr to control that
cutoff frequency so I'm using one adsr
to control the output envelope and
another adsr to control the cutoff
frequency okay yeah do it depends on the
design of the synthesizer and and and
what's going on for this emulation it
there's an easy way for us to set the
trigger for envelopes and you see this
little red light right there allows me
to set that that envelope is triggered
when a key press is set there's other
ways to trigger envelopes as well so
broto our very basic approach to vibrato
is done by simply using one of our
oscillator x' this is of course is why
we need so many oscillators because we
can use them for so many things using
one of our oscillator x' to control
modulate the frequency of our complex
tone
okay well maybe that doesn't sound much
like a normal vibrato so if we reduce
the degree of modulation
let's make it a little slower
okay well why don't we just make it
really wide so we can go from something
kind of like a normal vibrato to very
wide frequency sweeps we still don't
have something that sounds like a more
human vibrato does anybody know why we
don't have something that sounds like a
human vibrato anybody want to speculate
it's constant right the vibrato is
constant the whole time and often
musicians maybe start off with a
straight tone and then lean into the
vibrato and then stop the vibrato that's
right so we can yeah that's right
we use an envelope to scale the
amplitude of the low-frequency
oscillator that's driving the frequency
modulation again we use a what we do is
we take an adsr envelope that's being
triggered when the note starts and we're
putting that into one of our voltage
controlled amplifier x' we're taking the
output of one of our oscillators and
scaling the output by that adsr and
taking the output of that now modified
control signal to modulate the frequency
of our rich tone produced by three
oscillators which gives us
ever brought oh that nicely fades in and
then fades out what determines the fade
in time will it the attack of this
envelope so if we want it to come in
right away
we wanted to take a long time
the depth is set by our voltage control
amplifier okay maybe I went a little too
far there
okay
you get the idea so that's a great
example of using our modules for a lot
of different things we're using an
oscillator to create a variation in
frequency we're using one of our
envelopes to scale that variation before
applying it to other oscillators now as
we started to hear there we can push
this frequency modulation even further
and start to create new harmonics
frequency modulation or FM modulation is
when we modulate the frequency at or
near or beyond the audio rate producing
even more frequencies and an even more
complex Tambor frequency modulation is
often done with sine tones but what we
already have a rich tone so what if we
just modulate the frequency of our rich
tone at the audio rate I'll start with a
slow
you can hear it's already use low
frequency let me speed it up and as I
increase the amount of modulation
we get all sorts of new spectral
components due to the frequency
modulation and of course we could scale
that frequency modulation we could
modulate the modulator so we could
control the parameters of the modulation
with another oscillator or another
envelope and the process goes on and on
now a very common technique available
with as early as the RCA synthesizer
that we heard a little taste of this was
the use of filtered noise we can use our
noise sources through either a low pass
or bandpass filter to create some novel
Tambor's this was used in that example
we listened to before to create a sort
of drum sound and it can be used for a
lot of interesting sounds oh sorry
that was modulating the modulator of FM
here's our filter noise example so here
I'm using a white noise source into a
bandpass filter and I'm controlling the
cutoff frequency of that bandpass filter
by the keyboard so we can create
something somewhat in between a pitch
and unpitched sound if we try with a
low-pass filter so that's simply noise
through a low-pass filter where the
cutoff frequency is controlled by the
keyboard which gives us the ability to
create some novel sounds yeah yeah yeah
on the Moog I'm not sure I can do it on
this but with a computer we need to
insert a little bit of delay in there we
can do that we'll do that with PD when
we work this with PD well we'll feed
that back and see what happens you could
use feedback on the Moog particularly
with delay which is something that
sometimes people would use because we
still had the old tape technique so some
people would integrate tape delay with
the synthesizer send the signal out put
it through tape delay bring it back in
which allowed you to do some pretty
interesting things I believe we heard
that in the Oliv Eros tune a lien bog
she used a lot of tape delay the last
example I have for you guys is one of
the most common sounds from the modular
synthesizer or one of the additional the
many common sounds and this is using the
sample-and-hold
generator applied to noise so here what
I'm doing is taking white noise bringing
it into the sample-and-hold generator
the sample-and-hold takes that noise and
samples values from it in a periodic
fashion here I'm using the internal
trigger to sample the noise and I'm
applying the output of that to an
oscillator to do frequency modulation of
the oscillator so in short we get this
sound familiar
so what we're doing again we're taking
noise and using it as a source of
randomness but that noise is coming out
at the audio rate so basically what we
need to do is slow it down and the
sample-and-hold gives us a way to sort
of slow down a signal and make it into a
stepped pattern here it's really slow
I can speed it up
and even faster
and this sample-and-hold has a nice
glide parameter here which will smooth
out the transition between each step
until we don't even we spend all our
time gliding that we don't even get to
the point see sample and molds are a lot
of fun taking noise putting it through a
sample and hold a very powerful way to
get random parameters here we're hearing
those random parameters scaled in a very
wide frequency range we can use it in a
much more narrow range to create more
subtle effects let's see if we can hear
like a sort of random vibrato
I need to scale this even more
sort of a random vibrato very unhuman
approach and one very idiomatic to the
synthesizer questions well in a way I
mean the way that analog to digital
conversion works is essentially through
a process of sampling and holding a
value but sample-and-hold processors
were available for a long time yeah yeah
absolutely the ability but then with
this glide control we get right back
into the smooth analog domain so that's
that's yeah that's that's German so oh I
think it's a great interface but I don't
know of a virtualized version of those
EMS since yet they're ems really
explored that and there was another
synthesizer look at this our 2500 that
use more matrices that use matrices for
the entire patching system I would love
to see a virtualization of that but I
don't know if one yeah
max has a matrix GUI control yeah of
course with this design if it's
depending on how its implemented you can
do one-to-one connections like with a
patch Bay but you can also do one too
many connections as long as that doesn't
weaken your signal too much right so we
listen to a number of different pieces
using the modular synthesizer various
sorts probably some of the most
important in terms of the history of
music technology were those that were
released on the switched-on Bach album
this was released in 1968 by Wendy
Carlos and featured this very unhappy
looking guy well I guess he I don't know
supposed to be Bach he's got headphones
and he's sitting in front of the Moog
synthesizer this really solidifies the
some of the issues in music and
technology that we've seen again and
again new in order for new instruments
to be successful they often need to be
tied to historical practice and if you
want to legitimize an instrument well
play Bach on it and if you can play a
Bach on it then it's got to be
legitimate quotes of mogh and and others
talk about the importance of this album
in showing people what this thing was
what the synthesizer was that it could
be used as a musical instrument and
really inspired a whole generation or
generations of musicians to become
interested in the Moog
they say that sales of the Moog exploded
after the release of this album at least
for a couple of years even though the
mode was so expensive so I had you guys
listen to to brush our memory of these
first cantata 147
it is there this is one of my favorite
Tambor's in this whole album that's the
sort of filtered noise sound you can
hear there but it's got a little bit of
modulation on the frequencies so it's
kind of like there's a little vibrato on
it so there's that and then
well-tempered clavier booked one Prelude
and Fugue in C minor
nice huh what do you guys think yeah
great pleasant very pleasant I mean at
the time I imagined for some people they
were probably pretty jarring some of the
Tambor's like in that are pretty
strident tambores but it's still Bach
and it sort of relates to organ sounds
that you might associate some of these
sounds with other observations about
this there was some volume and that
Reich right there yeah you hear the sort
of stepped dynamics and that's because
if dynamics was a weak point of the mug
you couldn't you had a volume control
but you couldn't really the key boards
weren't velocity sensitive so adjusting
volume was was difficult so it was
probably well this album was recorded
through multitrack recordings so they
could do it in the mixing process
recording different layers or adjusting
the knobs it seems a little artificial
yeah you hear the step dynamics there
sensitive keys so yeah before we could
actually Express I'm not sure if they
were just on-off switches or if they had
some sort of like the more contact the
louder or something of the sort up and
down right yeah we have many devices
that even Mogis horn ribbons that would
use a lateral movement for for pitch but
I'm not sure when we got a really
flexible amplitude control into our
since it was a sequence it was all
performed live but it's a mistake to
think of this as just a demonstration of
the Moog synthesis of all tight track
recording and audio production because
this was all composed and performed one
part at a time recorded the tape and
layered one part at a time so taking
these large remember the mogh synthesis
entually a monophonic instrument at this
time and so they she had to play one
part at a time and layer and rerecord
and every time adjusting the tambour in
many ways this album i really recommend
you guys listen to the whole album
because it's fantastic it's sort of a
catalog of sounds you can make with the
Moog synthesizer and this was served as
a catalog for many others afterwards
going how did what was that sound what
was that sound trying to get the sounds
from that album really is sort of
resource for many other musicians I
think other confidence about this
depends a bit on the video this is the
carlo's Commission mode to build touch
sensitive keywords that have velocity oh
that's great was it before after this
okay
that's interesting yeah she worked with
mo quite a bit she worked with Moke to
create that demo mogh demo LP which I
sent you guys the link to she worked
with mo I think to improve the sequencer
design and that's an interesting issue
about the touch sensitive volume
sensitive keyboard it'd be interesting
to see when that came in and how that
was implied so that was a key point in
our history of music and technology the
sort of legitimization of the instrument
through Bach now something totally
different comes to us from the
Netherlands and this is a composition by
Gottfried Michele Koenig a composer a
German composer who had been living and
working in the Netherlands and he was
the artistic director of a place called
the Institute of 'some nology first in
utrecht and now in the hague where they
had over a period of a number of years
developed their own modular synthesizer
from scratch so while mogh led to the
first commercial packaged synthesizer
many people were developing custom-built
synthesizers that look something like
this where you have numerous individual
components often custom-designed
scattered around the room and a giant
patch bay to connect them all together
this synthesizer is still in existence
in fact I took this photo five years ago
this isn't historical it looks like that
still and it sounds fantastic it's an
amazing sounding synthesizer his
composition that we listen to grey
function is how it translate is part of
a series of function pieces that
explored automating some of the
parameters of the modular synthesizer
using a single sort of control voltage
as a pattern that was applied to
numerous different parameters of a
synthesis system we can hear a little
bit of this piece to remind you
now this piece was composed for four
channels and the four channels were kind
of composed independently so you can
kind of hear that in this two channel
mix you can sort of hear the four
sources independently moving thoughts
about this piece it's still going that
was interesting what do you think yeah I
mean I think if this piece providing a
sort of a landscape of noise textures
that we can make often we hear these
oscillators combined and used for pitch
sounds this composition really gives us
a sampling of the variety of noise
Tambor's that could be produced the
institute of stone ology synthesizer
also features a number of modules not
found on the mug for instance voltage
controlled envelope generators so where
the attack decay sustain release
parameters could be controlled by
voltages which is pretty interesting so
if you think about that you could set
the attack and the release of series of
sounds to be controlled by a low
frequency oscillator or something else
which allows you to create series of
dynamic envelopes right so moving on
Sebata Nick Silver Apples of the Moon
this piece was composed with a bucha
synthesizer it's not exactly clear how
much multi track layering was going on
in the production of this it's not clear
if this was one set up or if it was
multiple takes of layer that's something
to look at in the production of this
this composition was noted for being one
of the first recordings made for
commercial distribution with a
synthesizer it actually predates
predates switched-on Bach by a few years
but didn't have quite the commercial
success of switched-on Bach let's listen
to a little bit of this notice the
filter noise Tambor's coming out of the
speaker right there notice also the say
you had a Buchla and you wanted to
create that sort of flute like sounds
how much you do that any ideas it sounds
to me like an oscillator with a sort of
glide time with its pitch being
controlled by a sample and hold although
we're only getting a few couple pitches
that might be a way that some of the
frequencies are are chosen in this
composition using a sample and hold
adjusted and shifted to control the
frequencies what sort of musical rules
are we hearing are we hearing musical
rolls or parts that sound like acoustic
instruments or musical rules or parts
that sound like something totally
different I think that's a useful way
for us to approach some of these pieces
with the carlo's we hear sounds
synthesizer being used to emulate parts
that were done by acoustic instruments
in the current composition we heard
sounds that sound nothing like acoustic
instruments with this we have a nice
mixture of sounds that are somewhat
acoustic sounding in the rules and
somewhat electronic let's listen to a
little bit and think about which is
which
but that was a good point to do that
because our initial flute like sound
sort of transformed into something that
a flute player couldn't normally do now
in part b of this we get a very
surprising change we get this rhythmic
section building up at the end here
now buca's early synthesizers were often
notable for the use of the use of both
randomness and sequencers so he had
various types of random controllers that
were pretty novel your book mentions
that one of them was called a source of
uncertainty which is a very evocative
name for a random generator and also had
dedicated sequencers we're going to talk
about sequencers next time we meet but
we hear there some use of the sequencer
to create patterns of voltages that are
applied to pitch or their musical
parameters reflections on the speech
pieces did you like it as long it's long
right did you hear like sort of
accelerating and D accelerating sort of
articulations there's a sort of damper
really bad I say usual don't courtesy
start out with that one trip and that
tempers really bad [ __ ] yeah that's
interesting yeah although that was you
sampled here these were all synthesized
but yeah that's that's a good connection
anything else I think the the depth of
this composition is pretty remarkable
just there's just so much going on in
terms of background and foreground that
makes us such a thick composition there
had to be multitrack layering going on
in this composition I think either that
or they hooked up numerous since all
together in some massive piece all right
we have the Oliveros as well which is
probably the one of the most novel
compositions in that it doesn't sound at
all like Western instruments but really
takes advantage of the synthesizer in
some unique ways next time we meet we're
going to talk about the sequencer and
get continued our trajectory up to drum
machines I'll see you then see you guys
you